this video is about the friedman test
and we start right away with the first
question
what is the friedman test
the friedman test analyzes whether there
are statistically significant
differences between three or more
dependent samples
what is a dependent sample again
in a dependent sample the measured
values are linked for example if a
sample is drawn of people who have knee
surgery
and these people are interviewed before
the surgery and one and two weeks after
the surgery it is a dependent sample
this is the case because the same person
was interviewed at multiple time points
now you might rightly say that the
analysis of variance with repeated
measures tests exactly the same thing
since it also tests whether there is a
difference between three or more
dependent samples that is correct the
friedman test is the non-parametric
counterpart of the analysis of variance
with repeated measures
but what is the difference between the
two tests the analysis of variance tests
the extent to which the measured values
of the dependent sample differ in the
friedman test on the other hand it is
not the actual measured values that are
used but the ranks
the time where a person has the highest
value gets rank 1 the time with the
second highest value gets rank 2 and the
time with the smallest value gets rank
3.
this is now done for all people or for
all rows
afterwards the ranks of the single
points of time are added up at the first
time point we get a sum of seven
at the second time point we get a sum of
eight and at the third time point we get
a sum of nine
now we can check how much these rank
sums differ from each other
but why are rank sums used
the big advantage is that if you don't
look at the mean differences but at the
rank sum
the data doesn't have to be normally
distributed
to put it simple if your data are
normally distributed
parametric tests are used
for more than two dependent samples this
is the analysis of variance with
repeated measures
if your data are not normally
distributed
non-parametric tests are used
for more than two dependent samples this
is the friedman test
this leads us to the research question
that you can answer with the friedman
test
is there a significant difference
between more than two dependent groups
let's have a look at that with an
example
you might be interested to know whether
therapy after a slipped disc has an
influence on the patient's perception of
pain
for this purpose you measure the pain
perception before the therapy in the
middle of the therapy and at the end of
the therapy
now you want to know if there is a
difference between the different times
so your independent variable is time or
therapy progressing over time
your dependent variable is the pain
perception you now have a history of the
pain perception of each person over time
and now you want to know whether the
therapy has an influence on the pain
perception
simplified in this case the therapy has
an influence
and in that case the therapy has no
influence on the pain perception
in the course of time the pain
perception does not change here
in this case it does
now we also have a good transition to
the hypotheses
in the friedman test the null hypothesis
is there are no significant differences
between the dependent groups
and the alternative hypothesis is
there is a significant difference
between the dependent groups
of course as already mentioned the
friedman test does not use the true
values but the ranks we will go through
the formula behind the friedman test in
a moment this brings us to the point of
how to calculate the friedman test for
the calculation of the friedman test you
can of course simply use datadep or
calculate it by hand to be honest hardly
anyone will calculate the friedman test
by hand
but it will help you to understand how
the friedman test works and don't worry
it's not that complicated
first i will show you how to calculate
the friedman test with datatab and then
i will show you how to do it by hand
in order to do this simply go to
datadeb.net
and copy your own data into this table
let's say you want to investigate
whether there is a difference in the
response time of people in the morning
at noon and in the evening
we simply click on this tab
under this tab you will find many
hypothesis tests and data tab will
automatically suggest an appropriate
test
if we click on all three variables
morning noon and evening
data tab will automatically calculate an
analysis of variance with repeated
measures
but in our case we want to calculate the
non-parametric test so we click here now
we get the results for the friedman test
up here you can read the descriptive
statistics
and down here you can find the p-value
if you don't know exactly how to
interpret the p-value
you can just read the interpretation in
words down here
a fragment has shown that there is no
significant difference between the
variables
chi-square equals 2.57
p equals 0.276
[Music]
if your p-value is greater than your set
significance level
then your null hypothesis is retained
the null hypothesis is that there is no
difference between the groups
usually a significance level of 0.05 is
used so this p-value is greater than
0.05
additionally datatab gives you the post
hoc test
if your p-value is smaller than
0.05 the post-talk test helps you to
examine
which of the groups really differ so now
let's look at what the equation behind
the friedman test are and recalculate
this example by hand
here we have the measured values of the
seven people
in the first step we have to assign
ranks to the values
in order to do this we look at each row
separately
in the first row which is the first
person
45 is the largest value
this gets rank 1
then comes 36
with rank 2 and 34 with rank 3.
we do the same for the second row here
36 is the largest value and gets rank 1
then comes 33 with rank 2
and 31 with rank 3.
now we do this for each row so for all
people
afterwards we can calculate the rank sum
for each point in time for example we
just sum up all ranks at one point in
time
in the morning we get 17 at noon 11 and
in the evening 14.
if there were no differences between the
different time points in terms of
reaction time
we would expect the expected value at
all time points
the expected value is obtained with this
formula
and in this case it is 14.
so if there is no difference between
morning noon and evening we would
actually expect a rank sum of 14 at all
three time points
next we can calculate the chi-square
value
we get it with this formula
n is the number of people which is 7
k is the number of time points so 3
and the sum of r squared is 17 squared
plus 11 squared plus 14 squared
so we get a chi-square value of 2.57
now we need the number of degrees of
freedom this is given by the number of
time points minus one so in our case two
finally we can read the critical
chi-square value in the table of
critical chi-square values
for this we take the predefined
significance level let's say it is
0.05 and the number of degrees of
freedom here we can read that the
critical chi-square value is 5.99
this is greater than our calculated
value
therefore the null hypothesis is not
rejected and based on these data there
is no difference between the
responsiveness at the different time
points
therefore the null hypothesis is not
rejected and based on these data there's
no difference between the responsiveness
at the different time points
if the calculated chi-square value was
greater than the critical one we would
reject the null hypothesis
i hope you enjoyed the video and see you
next time